- Welcome back, everyone
for our discussion session
following Professor Alex
Paseau's talk yesterday.
And I am delighted to
introduce our conversant
for this afternoon, Professor Gila Sher
of the University of
California at San Diego.
We are delighted to have you here
and Alex we are delighted
to have you back.
And as a philosophy professor
her research interests
have focused on the foundational
issues in epistemology,
the philosophy of logic
and the theory of truth.
Her books include "The Bounds of Logic:
A Generalized Viewpoint" from MIT Press,
"Epistemic Friction: An Essay
on Knowledge, Truth and Logic"
from Oxford University Press
and "Logical Consequence"
from the Cambridge University Press.
She's currently working on
a book provisionally titled,
"Truth as a Human Value,"
which sounds fascinating,
which offers a reconception
of the philosophy of truth
in light of the post-truth crisis.
So without further ado,
let me invite Professor
Gila Sher to take the floor.
- Thank you.
Okay, I would like first to
thank Priya for inviting me
to be a discussant and
I'd like to thank Alex
for an extremely
interesting talk yesterday.
I also listened to some of
the talks on your webpage
and they're really fascinating.
So I started by short introduction,
There's Much More to
Logic Than Recognized,
and this is a citation from Alex.
Now, I agree with most of
the things that Alex says
about true, sorry, about logic.
There is much more to logic
than commonly recognized.
One of the things is
that logic is not finite
in ways it is commonly thought to be.
In addition to a bottom-up
way of understanding logic
based on the way we commonly
use it in everyday discourse,
there is also a top-down
theoretical understanding of logic
that shows that logic is
stronger than commonly thought.
A very important theoretical
consideration of this kind
is the strong degree
of invariance of logic
that Alex talked about.
This has to do with the topic neutrality
and other special features
of logic such as formality,
necessity, and generality.
But there are also significant relations
between purely logical
or deductive inferences
and non-logical, non-deductive inferences.
Not all good inferences, I
agree with Alex, are logical.
Since I agree with Alex,
I won't criticize him,
but I approach logic
from a somewhat different
perspective than him.
So I will try to broaden the perspective,
hence the significance of
what Alex said about logic
and I will ask him if he
agrees with this broadening.
Among other things I will address
the question of truth in
logic and I will try to give
a tentative answer to two of the questions
that Priya asked Alex yesterday,
what is special to the
structure of mathematics
compared to physics and why?
And I would add whether mathematics
can't be affected by experimentation?
Let's start with truth.
Alex gave a simple example
of a logical inference
or implication, I will use
them interchangeably here.
If the inference is if
A, then B: if B, then C:
therefore, if A, then C, and
here it is in symbols too.
Now, is it true that this is
a logically valid inference?
Or take this inference,
for some X, PX or QX, for all X, not PX,
therefore for some X, QX.
Is it true that this
inference is logically valid?
Now, the above inferences
seem to be logically valid,
but is it true that
they are logically valid
and if it is, why?
And does this answer extend
to infinitary inferences
like the ones that Alex talked about?
Some people say that there is no truth
and falsehood in logic.
Logic is just a game and like all games
the logical game has its rules
which tell us when we
win and when we lose,
but this has nothing to do with truth.
For example, the late Wittgenstein said
that logic is a language game.
Carnap said that logic
is merely conventional.
There is no right and wrong in logic.
There is only what we like
or what is convenient.
This leads to a pragmatist, relativist
and pluralist views of logic.
Alex, I should note, is an anti-pluralist,
he is a monist about logic.
His book is titled "The One True Logic."
Now, even if you believe
that there is truth and falsehood in logic
and that it's true
that the above inferences
are logically valid,
the question arises why
or in virtue of what?
Is it true that there are logically valid?
Some philosophers, perhaps
most philosophers say
that this is a matter of language.
Logical inferences are analytic.
English users treat
them as logically valid.
When we put these two approaches together,
we arrive at the view
that logical inferences
are just winning moves in a language game.
And this was Wittgeinstein's view.
What I wanna show is that
logic is neither a game
nor grounded merely in language.
I will do this first in a
bottom-top way by an example.
Claim, logic is not just a language game.
Logic must be constrained by the world.
Truth in the world can be a matter
of life and death in logic,
not just winning or losing a game.
And being constrained
by the world makes logic
similar to physics and other sciences.
Here is a short story
that demonstrates this.
Abe is a young naive
student at University X.
He takes seriously
everything his professors,
especially his more extravagant
professors teach him.
One day a new logic professor
joins Abe's university,
and he's eccentric, extravagant
and exciting as Abe likes.
The new professor tells students
that logic is nothing more than a game.
He shares with them one
of his favorite rules
which belongs to a new,
non-traditional logic game he invented.
He calls this rule modus davka.
Now, davka is a Hebrew
word which means willfully,
spitefully, deliberately
doing the opposite
of what you are expected to do.
And the rule modus davka is the following,
first we have a premise if A, then not B,
then we have the premise
A, and we conclude B.
Abe is excited about modus davka.
He decides to follow it
in his everyday life.
Modus davka is not a
traditional rule of inference.
It's superficially similar to an instance
of a traditional logical
rule, modus ponens
which the instance would say
if A, then not B, A, therefore not B.
But it's different.
Standing on the side of a
busy road in town one day,
Abe is getting ready to cross it.
His parents told him if a car is coming
don't cross the road,
Abe takes one to be true.
It is the conditional command
analog of a true sentence,
hence essentially true.
Abe checks whether a car is coming
and sees that one is
coming, indeed many are.
Remembering his new exciting teacher's
favorite logical rule,
MD: If A, then not B; A therefore: B,
Abe crosses the road, Abe dies.
MD may be an exciting rule
but it does not work in the world.
In contrast rules that
are grounded in the world
like modus ponens do.
Modus ponens is grounded in the world.
It says if A then not
B, A therefore not B.
Had Abe followed MP instead of MD,
he would not have crossed the road
and would not have been killed by a car,
at least at that time.
Now, this was a bottom-up
argument for the claim
that logic is constrained by the world,
but can we establish it also
using a top-down theoretical argument?
Can we establish this by an argument about
the nature of logic of
the kind used by Alex
to establish the infinitary
cocktail of logic?
I think we can, but first
I would like address
the methodological issue
of providing a top-down
theoretical foundation for logic.
Is it possible to provide
a foundation for logic?
Many philosophers believe
that it's impossible.
To provide a foundation for X, they say,
you have to go outside X, but
we cannot go outside logic,
we cannot make any step in
thought without using logic.
A foundation for logic will be circular.
This was the view of
the young Wittgenstein
and many past and present
philosophers share.
I don't, why?
The methodology used in
foundational studies in philosophy,
the traditional one is foundationalism.
It says that in order to provide
a foundation for knowledge,
all units of knowledge have to be grounded
in something which is lower than them
in the foundational
hierarchy until in the end
they're all grounded in the base.
The problem is that there is
nothing lower than the base.
So it is in principle
impossible to ground the base.
Since everything depends on the base,
nothing can be grounded.
In the case of logic, it's more direct
because everyone puts logic in the base.
What I believe is that
there is more than one
foundational methodology and
a more fruitful methodology
is what I call foundational wholism,
here we have our system of knowledge.
Different branches and different parts
are connected to the world in
different ways in many places
and they are all connected
also among themselves.
In order to arrive at knowledge
or to give a foundation for knowledge,
we have to ground it on
the one hand in the world
through these all connections
and we can also help ourselves
by utilizing the connections,
the internal connections
between fields of knowledge.
The process is dynamic
and it goes in a back and forth manner.
Once we have a tentative
foundation for something,
we move to another part of
our system of knowledge,
use new resources that
we got in the meantime
and we examine our original foundation.
Whenever there is secularity,
it is usually temporary and partial.
It is partial because we
always use many sources
in order to find something.
For example, in the case of
logic, we use philosophy,
mathematics, general
knowledge, common sense,
besides using logic and
it's all also temporary
because we always come back
and reexamine our foundation
and assume different things and put aside
things we assume in the past.
So using the foundational
holistic methodology,
one way to go about providing a foundation
for logic is this,
we start observations about knowledge,
one, for one reason or another
human beings are interested
in knowing the world as it is,
but, two, such knowledge does
not come to them automatically
and in many cases it is
quite difficult to arrive at.
This is largely due to the limitations
of our cognitive resources.
One result of these limitations
is that we are prone to error.
This is where truth
enters into the picture.
We need truth, we need a
norm or a standard of truth
to avoid error.
Another result is that we need shortcuts.
We cannot discover each facet
of the world individually.
This is where methods of
inference come into play.
We would especially benefit
from having a genuine method
for arriving from truth
that we already know
to truth that we don't yet know.
The function of logic is
to provide such a method.
Now, because our goal is
true theories of the world,
it's very important that logical
influence transmits truth,
truth in the world from
premises to conclusion.
And it's also very
desirable that logic provide
a strong method of transmitting truth,
one that works in all
almost fields of knowledge
and even for cases we
have not encountered yet
but might encounter in the future
that is counterfactual cases.
So the task of logic is to
provide a method of inference
that transmits truth from
premises to conclusion
with a considerable modal
force and generality.
A logically implies B, if
only if A transmits truth
to be necessarily and in all fields.
But is this possible?
I think it is.
And I reason as follows,
if one, in the world,
if one, the world has certain
features that occur everywhere
including all parts of the world
that the different
fields of knowledge study
and including counterfactual situations.
And if two, these features
are governed by laws
which are both highly
general and highly necessary,
then we could use our
knowledge of these laws
to create a general and
necessary method of inference,
a method for transmitting
truth from sentences
that are true in the
world to other sentences
that are true in the world.
Expanding our knowledge to
the latter in one fell swoop.
This is what we are looking for,
features or properties F1,
F2 in the world such that
looking from the bottom-up,
it is a law that F1 necessitates F2.
So in the world a situation C1 that has F1
necessitates situation C2 that has F2,
and if S1 is true, just
in case C1 is the case
and S2 is true just in
case C2 is the case,
then the necessation and
the level of the world
ensures that the truth
of S1 strongly guarantees
the truth of S2, and this is
a basis for the inference,
S1 logically implies S2.
Now, are there such
properties like F1 and F2?
Yes, formal properties are of this kind.
Properties like identity,
complementation, union,
intersection, cardinality
properties such as
at least one having finite
cardinality and et cetera.
Note that at least one
is the same property
as non-emptiness,
which is the existential
quantifier of property,
to say that there is at least
one P is the same as saying
P is not empty, which
is the same as saying
there is an X such that PX.
Now, all the standard logical
constants and the properties
they denote are intuitively formal,
and this explains how
and why standard logical
content implications work.
For example, take the
implication for some X, AX or BX
for all X not BX,
therefore for some X, AX.
The premises transmit truth
necessarily to the conclusion
because in the world
there has a formal law
which says that the
non-emptiness of any union
of any properties P1 and P2
plus the emptiness of P2,
here B is empty, necessitates
the non-emptiness of P1.
This explains why the above
inference transmits truth
from premises to conclusion
and does so in all field
and with strong necessity.
All field, for example, in a
case of the natural numbers
A and B can be positive and negative,
properties of being positive and negative,
there is at least one number
which is positive or negative.
No natural number is negative,
therefore at least one is positive.
And in the field of say
American presidents,
these could be the properties
of being a man and a woman.
So there is at least
one American president,
which is a man or a woman.
So far there are no American
presidents which are women,
therefore there is at
least one which is a man.
Now, it is important to recognize that
there are more formal
properties than formal laws
and formal laws and more formal laws
than those underlined the
inferences of standard logic.
Okay, this correlates with
the point Alex made yesterday.
For example, the properties
is infinite is uncountable,
the second level properties are formal.
And uncountable P necessitates
infinite P is a formal law.
So the inference uncountable many X, PX,
therefore infinitely many
X, PX also transmits truth
from premise to conclusion
with a strong modal force,
hence it is logical valid.
We have done two things.
One, we have provided a foundation
for standard logical inferences,
and two, we expanded standard logic
based on the same foundation.
But we also did a third thing.
We expanded logic and inferences
to inferences that deal with infinities.
Such inferences are not
recognized by standard logic.
This is another aspect of the
infinitary character of logic
and as we should shortly see,
it is equivalent to the
infinitary character
of Alex's infinitary
logic which has to do with
infinitely long conjunctions,
disjunctions and quantifications.
But in order to reach this result
and in order to further systematize
our foundation of logic,
we need to systematically
characterize formality,
formal properties.
And this leads us to the
fascinating topic of invariance,
that Alex talked about.
Invariance is a central topic of interest
in both science and mathematics.
But the invariance used
in the foundation of logic
is a bit different, it
is property invariance,
let me explain.
Every property whatsoever has
some degree of invariance.
What does this mean?
It means that every
property remains the same
under some one-to-one and onto
replacements of individuals.
Example, the property is a human.
If you replace individuals which are men
by individuals which are
women in a one-to-one manner,
the property is a human will not notice,
it is invariant under such replacement.
Most properties, however,
are not invariant
under all one-to-one and on to
replacements of individuals.
For example, is a human, is
invariant under replacements
of men by women but not under replacements
of men by numbers.
When we replaced Biden by the number one
and Trump by the number two
and Obama by the number three,
and so on, we replace
the property, is a human,
by the property is a number.
But some properties are
invariant under all one-to-one
and onto replacements of individuals.
For example, self-identity.
Biden is self-identical and so is one,
Trump is self-identical and so is two,
and similarly Obama and three.
Indeed maximally invariant
properties are invariant
not just under one-to-one replacements
of actual individuals,
but also under one-to-one replacements
of counterfactual individuals.
For example, identity is
invariant under all one-to-one
and onto replacements of actual
counterfactual individuals.
If we replace Biden then
by Hamlet for example,
we also replace an individual
which is identical to itself
and only to itself by an
individual which is identical
to itself and only to itself.
Identity is not affected
by such a replacement.
In fact, all the formal
properties in our examples above
are of this kind.
Consider is known empty,
the existential quantifier property.
Take any domains with the
same number of individuals,
for example, D1 is Biden, Trump, Obama
and D2, one, two, three.
Now, replace the members
of D1 by members of D2
in a one-to-one manner,
for example as above.
Next take any property of objects in D1,
say is a Democratic president.
This property satisfies
non-emptiness in D1
but also its image under
the one-to-one replacement
is non-empty, its image is the property
A being an odd numbers,
Biden is correlated with one
and Obama with three, and these
property also is non-empty.
So non-emptiness does
not notice is invariant
under this replacement,
and this holds generally.
Let us call properties that are invariant
under all one-to-one and onto replacements
of actual counterfactual individuals
maximally invariant properties.
We seem to have two very
interesting results.
One, all the standards logical properties,
the properties denoted
by the logical constants
are maximally invariant.
Two, other properties including
infinitistic properties
such as infinitely many
and accountably many
are also maximally invariant.
We also have results that enable us
to give a precise definition of formality.
A property P is maximally
invariant if and only if
it is invariant under all isomorphisms.
What does this mean?
For example, identity is invariant
and that does not distinguish between
any isomorphic structures
of the form D domain
and a pair of individuals A, B.
A is identical to be and the
structure DAB is isomorphic
to the structure D prime, A prime, B prime
if and only if A prime
is identical to B prime.
Now, intuitively a property
is isomorphism invariant
if and only if it is highly structural.
It follows from one
and two that a property
is maximally invariant if and only if
it is highly structural.
And since to be formal is intuitively
to be highly structural, we
now have a precise definition
of formality, property P
is formal is by definition
P is maximally invariant.
Another interesting result
is if a property is formal,
the laws governing it
are highly necessary.
Reason, if a property does not distinguish
between any actual
counterfactual individuals,
its laws cannot distinguish
between them either.
If they hold in any domain
of actual counterfactual individuals,
they hold in all domains
hence they are necessary.
It follows, all implications
based on formal laws are necessary.
This explains why all the
standard logical implications
as well as infinitistic implications
like uncomfortably many X, PX,
therefore infinitely
many X, PX are necessary.
They transmit truth from
premises to conclusion
with a very strong modal force,
hence they satisfy the requirements
and logical implications,
I.e, they are logically valid.
Next we arrived at Mcgee's result
that Alex relied on yesterday.
A property is formal if
and only if it is definable
in the logic L infinity, infinity.
This means that all infinitary
implications in Alex's sense
are logical.
Finally, there is an interesting
concerning mathematics.
All higher level mathematical
properties are formal.
Now, since all mathematical individuals
and their lower level mathematical
properties are correlated
with higher level mathematical properties,
all of mathematics is essentially formal.
What do I mean by this correlation?
For example, the number one
which is a mathematical
individual is correlated
with the second level
mathematical property exactly one
as in there is exactly one moon of earth,
and this is how it's
usually used in science.
Let me conclude with a few
results concerning the difference
and similarities between
mathematics and science.
Differences between
mathematics and science,
and this addresses the points
that Priya raise yesterday.
The fact that mathematics is
formal maximally invariant
explains what is special
about mathematics.
Mathematics is maximally invariant,
hence its laws are highly necessary.
Physical properties are
not maximally invariant.
Their laws have a weaker necessity
than the logical mathematical laws.
For example, physical laws
distinguish between numbers
and physical objects
they hold of the latter
but not of the format.
Because physical concern
physical properties
which are not maximally invariant,
they are generally not
relevant to mathematics.
They don't make a
difference to mathematics.
Mathematics does not notice
that, it is blind to that.
On the other hand, there
are also similarities
between mathematics and
science, as Alex pointed
or in the spirit of what he pointed out.
A, although mathematical
properties, I'm sorry,
physical properties are
not maximally invariant,
some physical properties
like being subject to gravity
have a fairly strong degree of invariance.
They are invariant under all one-to-one
and onto replacements of
physically possible individuals.
Any replacement of physical individuals,
will get you from individual,
which is subject to gravity
to an individual which
is subject to gravity.
And even in the counterfactual case,
say a second moon of earth,
that will be the case,
a second moon of earth
will be subject to gravity.
Therefore, their laws also have
a fairly strong degree of necessity.
B, because physical objects and properties
have formal properties,
for example, the property
of being a moon of earth,
the physical property
has the formal property
of having cardinality one,
mathematics and logic,
which are formal theories are
widely applicable to physics.
They deal with formal properties
which are properties of physical objects
and physical properties.
This gives a new answer to
Wagner's famous question
about the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics
and I would add logic
in the natural sciences.
The fact that physical
objects have formal properties
and are governed by
formal laws explains also
how sometimes physical results
are relevant to mathematics.
Whenever we get a new refutation
of a scientific conjecture,
there is a possibility
that the mistake concerns
formal assumptions we made
concerning the physical situation.
This gives us a motivation to reexamine
our formal assumptions
and our background mathematical
theories more generally.
I will end with a question to Alex,
my philosophical understanding
of logic and mathematics
support and expands many of your results,
but people can agree on some things
yet give them different
philosophical explanations.
Are these philosophical
explanations of your result
in agreement with your own
general philosophical conception
of logic?
And if not, what is your take
on the philosophical foundation
of logic, logical inference,
which underlies from your
point of your results?
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Gila
for engaging both with Alex
and many of the questions,
mine and others that came up yesterday.
So Alex, the floor is
first yours to bring up
any points of agreement
or disagreement or nuance
that you would like us to learn
from a conversation with Gila.
- Thank you very much,
Gila for this very careful
and insightful discussion.
As Priya said both of my
talk have had questions
on the subject matter.
I think I should start
by saying that Gila and I
are so overwhelmingly in agreement
that we can have a discussion
of our differences,
but that should not obscure
the fact that we agree
on so much of the terrain here.
And in particular we agree
on this key feature of logic
that it's infinite, most
technically infinitary,
that we both discussed today.
And that puts us in a
small minority actually
in today's intellectual climate.
But nonetheless, we both think it,
for fairly similar reasons.
Although Gila, she indicated today adds,
I would characterize it this way,
adds another layer to it, a deeper layer
than the one that I mentioned,
the reasons that I gave,
she gives a foundation
as she said from her
foundational holist perspective.
I'm happy to open the
floor to other people
before we start talking
about those small differences
because I wanna emphasize
that they are small
and we will get to Gila's
question to me at the end,
but I think it might be
better to ask other people
to intervene rather than emphasize
some rather small differences.
- Okay, great.
So I think I'm gonna take the bait
and ask a few clarifying questions.
So I have a couple, but let
me start off with the one.
So from what you've said that
potentially the difference
between say, physics
and mathematics arises,
is it really the existence of laws,
but then laws are not
really quite reliable
in the same way as proofs.
So the physical laws
are not quite the analog
but because a law as is
not a permanently stable
and beyond approach
end all like a proof is
in terms of a description.
So I was curious about
what is the role of laws
when you consider I got
a sense that somehow
laws are very much part
of what distinguishes,
so the law of gravitation, the
fact that it is indisputable
in a certain way is makes
it very much like a proof.
But am I missing something?
I'm not entirely sure if...
- Yeah, okay, so the way I
think about it is like this,
laws in all fields are
associated with some properties.
So you say we have the laws of gravities,
the laws of motions, they are associated
with properties in logic,
although we talked about
inferences, we also have laws,
the laws of non-contradiction,
the laws of identity,
the laws of excluded middle,
of disjunction and so on.
So they are always
associated with properties.
Now, especially in physics today,
in the philosophy of physics,
not in physics, I don't
know how it is in physics
but in the philosophy of physics,
many people question whether
there are laws at all.
And this is a big question.
And one of the things
that I want to emphasize,
that one similarity that
there is between logical
and mathematical laws
and physical laws is that
some physical principles
have a very high degree of invariance.
It's not as high as a degree
of invariance of logical
or mathematical laws,
but the physical laws
are generally associated
with properties that have a
high degree of invariance.
For example, you don't have a
law of the Mountain Everest,
which is, being a Mountain Everest
has very low degree of invariance.
You have laws of gravity,
of mass, of motion,
of things like this
that have a very high
degree of invariance.
I cannot-
- There's a degree of invariance,
but there is a domain of validity,
which you do not have in laws
of mathematics, if you will,
or laws of logic, if you will.
So again, coming back
to Newton and Einstein,
there's a domain of validity
where a Newtonian description
is not only sufficient, but
it's excellent and it is enough,
sufficient, necessary and
enough to describe the world
and motions and everything
that we can experience.
However, that is not the last word on.
So it is a domain validity and
there's a domain beyond which
it's no longer valid.
So there conditionality to laws in physics
like domain of validity for
properties which you do not have
in mathematics, like a proof
is a result that is truth,
that is stable and there
are no conditionals there.
- Well, not exactly, at least in my view.
I mean, proofs in mathematics,
as Alex mentioned yesterday,
are usually based on certain axioms.
And so there are based on certain theory,
which is its identity is
determined by its axioms,
and if you accept the
axioms, the proof is a proof.
But there is a question of
whether you accept the axioms.
And in the same way that in mathematics,
when you look at things
in a certain perspective,
in certain scope it seems
that the laws are perfect.
But then when you look
in a broader perspective,
you see no, they're not
perfect, they work well,
they agree with the narrow perspective,
but not the broader perspective.
The same thing can happen
also in mathematics,
and in fact, even in logic.
And one of my colleagues, Penelope Mari,
brought a very interesting
example, she's not the first,
but she worked out I think beautifully
that also connects logic to physics.
And that's the question
of quantum mechanics,
where some physicists and
philosophers of logic thought
that the microscopic domain
turns out to be formally different
from the microscopic domain.
And that, for example, it's not bullion
and that might require that we have
a different logic for you.
Now, for me it's a possibility.
I would not say that this
is actually the case,
but I think in principle it's possible.
So in the same way that you
moved from Newton to Einstein,
we might move from bullion logic
to some other kind of logic.
Now, it's less likely there are fewer,
there's a smaller likelihood
of changes in logic
because of the enormous
invariance of its principles,
most discoveries it
doesn't pay attention to.
But that's not always the case.
So even in this way, I think
there are more similarities
but also differences.
- If I may pitch in at this point,
and I wanna follow-up on
this, but I also wanna pick up
a question in the Q&A by Joel.
So from my point of view,
mathematics is a fallible
enterprise like any other,
and what I said yesterday
about non-deductive inference
in mathematics in a way is
supported by that thought.
If deductive inference
was somehow infallible,
it was just this infallible
way of getting you
from truth to truth,
there would be something special about it.
But to say that there's a bias here
in just the choice of terminology.
The word proof is a success word.
So of course if you've gotta
proof, it's successful,
but the human practice of mathematics
is a highly fallible one.
So Joel in the chat brought
up the world's proof,
attempted proof in '93
of Farmer's last term,
which was fallacious, there was a gap,
which he then took a
couple of years to fix
with one of his colleague.
And I think that is just
an example on ground
and highly publicized
scale of the fact that
mathematics is a human endeavor
and people get things wrong.
So there isn't anything,
I mean, mathematics, it's
easier to spot mistakes,
that is true
and there is perhaps a
higher degree of certainty,
but it's not 100% and it's
a human fallible enterprise
like any other, just a little
bit more along the range.
- Yeah, and I will also
add to what Alex said
that the case of Wides proof
ended up being success,
but in logic, for
example, we have this case
in which on the one hand,
Frege revolutionized logic
or maybe with the background
of other people around him,
but Russell discovered
a paradox in his logic,
an error, a fatal error and
this could not be corrected.
At the same time, there are
still things that can be done.
And so Russell himself
built a logic that included
many of Frege principles,
but not the principles
that led to the paradox.
And then there were other ways
of doing it, like set theory,
axiomatic set theory and
first order logic and so on,
and so in mathematics and logic,
it's not that always you fix it,
sometimes you can be completely wrong
and have to reject something as a result.
- Great, thanks.
Let me see if there are
any other questions.
- So just to answer, Joel,
Joel had a second part to his question.
There could be a flaw even
in the patched up proof.
I mean, it was 100 pages long,
highly sophisticated proof
and what we don't think there is,
but they could well be.
In fact, there's a interesting story
of a great mathematician,
Vladimir Voevodsky,
who was a field medalist
and he was so shocked
by a major error in a
proof that he decided
that it was about time that mathematics
formalized its proofs and there
were much more sophisticated
computer theorem the checkers
in order to eliminate error
as much as possible.
And that has helped, but
it hasn't gone all the way
because I just don't think
you can go all the way.
- Actually as we wait
for somebody else to,
that was actually going to be my question
that is it true that...
So I'm curious why you
said that a computer
will not be able to infallibly
all the time discover flaws.
- Okay, so a computer
will improve efficiency.
But it is a machine like any other,
and that has to be tested,
that could be problems.
And there's also gonna
be bounds on capacity.
So maybe for short proofs it's
gonna be able to cover them,
but very long ones, maybe we won't be able
to have for physical reasons
not be able to build one
that managers to check
very long proofs and so on.
Sure it's many steps
in the right direction.
And you've gotta also
think about how you feed
our human proof into a computer.
- Right.
- How do you translate it in
such a way that the computer
can check it, that process
has not been mechanized
and that is a possible
source of error as well.
- So I mean there aren't
AI algorithms that are,
so in physics for example,
they recently demonstrated that
for Kepler's laws, they said
that if you fed a computer
just the planetary positions, orbits,
the information that Kepler
really knew at the time,
then what could the computer
infer from that data?
Of course, you have to
request that it recovers
some correlation on law,
and then surprise, surprise,
of course, it does recover Kepler's laws.
And that was very surprising
to us in the community,
but somehow, because many reasons,
one of course, is the unique creative,
it allows us to keep
intact this whole idea
of human creativity and the
individual and so on so forth.
But I'm curious whether
there have been attempts
to harness AI to mathematize
the notion of proofs
and are there algorithms?
I think there was a project
called the Bacon Project,
wasn't there?
- I don't know about that particular one,
but the answer to your question is yes,
and in fact there's lots
of formal proof checkers
and not just that these
days there's also AI
that suggests theorems.
So I think there was an
article earlier this year
or last year in the
Scientific American or Analog
about proofs in topology
that the AI was taught
a bit of topology, algebraic topology
and just came up with some
conjecture that it proved itself.
So that's definitely on the rise.
But going back to my earlier point,
the way that normal
standard proofs are written
in a journal or communicated
in a lecture room,
they're very wrapped up in human language,
in human modes of thought.
And so we are not yet at the point
at which we can
mechanically translate those
and completely be sure that
we've checked for the validity.
That might come, I'm
not saying it will not,
but we're not there yet.
- I actually have a question to Priya
about something you mentioned just now,
and that's creativity supposedly
as opposed to what computers are doing.
So it may be disappointing
if what someone derived it creatively
could derive it simply
by a computer proof.
In philosophy, usually when
people think about creativity,
they think about it
in terms of some kind
of immediate intuition
and in psychology also people
talk about an aha moment
or something like this.
But it strikes me that this is not
the only form of creativity
and that we're also creating
and also use intellect, not
just by this kind of intuition,
but ways of figuring out these things.
And that brings us closer,
the creativity closer
to what a computer can do.
But I think that this is also
related to what I talked about
earlier about holism in that
one very important aspect
in creativity, I think,
and in figuring things out
that we can always switch
perspective, we can always go
beyond the place where
we are and look at it
and look at other things
and connect them and may try
to figure out things this way.
So the dynamics maybe of
human creativity is different
from the dynamics of computers but-
- But I think that, so
in physics, for example,
we increasingly know that
scientists own narrative
of their discoveries are highly incomplete
and they don't quite reflect
the range of activities
because we are so fixated on this idea
of the lone male genius
and this aha moment,
this eureka moment, that
our own personal recounting
of our own discoveries is not reliable.
But what appears to be a
robust fact across questions,
across individuals is the
fact that the insight,
if you really drill down into what is new,
what was the leap, so it turns
out that the creative leap
appears to be the ability to connect
different domains of knowledge
which appear entirely unrelated at first.
So we are not just talking of tools,
you're not talking of language,
we are not talking of
methodologies of investigation
or anything, but really the
formal representation of ideas
and properties of objects,
in the case of physics,
across domains
and that it's a language
translation exercise, if you will,
that is more than just the language,
it's a conceptual domain mapping
that we do when new discoveries are made.
And you are right, if
inherently that is a key part
of what we call human creativity,
that is hard to replicate in a computer
because what we feed in
is what the computer operates out of.
So you would ultimately
need to have a computer
that has a training set in
every domain of knowledge
and then see if it can do
the kind of connection making
and synthesis that we
believe that human minds
have the capacity to do.
- Priya, I don't know if this
is a good moment to discuss
one of the differences between Gila and me
and the question she raised at the end.
Okay, so just to very
briefly summarize it,
Gila and I agree on this
very important claim
that logic is infinite,
and we give similar sorts
of arguments for it,
but she founds it on another layer,
this idea of formal laws and
formal features of the world.
Now, I don't disagree with that.
It's not that I agree with it either,
is I am undecided as to whether
to say something like that.
And I have three sources of hesitation.
So I'll mention what those
sources of hesitation are.
The first is really
more of a pragmatic one.
I think for dialectical purposes,
if we wanna convince people
that logic is infinite,
then adding a metaphysical
layer, if you like,
might be a step too far for some people,
that's not a reason against it,
it's just a dialectical point
and why it doesn't feature
heavily in my book.
Because getting people today
to agree that logic is infinite
is already quite a big task.
The second source of hesitation is that
on the standard conception of logic,
model theoretical conception,
the models that we quantify
over when we consider
whether the premises entail
the conclusion we formalize,
those in the logic and
we consider the models
of the premises and see
whether all those models
are also models of the conclusion,
those models standard understanding
do not include the whole universe
because they're sets and
they're not the class
that is the whole universe.
So in a way it's a little
strange to couple that,
combine that standard understanding,
which is a standard understanding
which can be adopted
on the infinite view of logic as well.
It's strange to combine that
perhaps uneasy to combine that
with the idea that logic is
about the formal features
of reality, if reality's not
actually one of those models.
And then the third source of hesitation.
And it's not disagreement,
it's just hesitation
about going that far, I wanna stress,
is I'm not sure how much explanation
of the fact that logic is infinite
by adding this layer of saying that
the world has four more features.
It seems to be redescribing
the fact of logic's infinity
in more metaphysical
language, laws and structures
and so on.
I'm not saying it doesn't
go further, it does seem to,
but it seems quite close to
what we were saying before
to really be a powerful explanation of it
as opposed to a redescription.
So those are my three
sources of hesitation, Gila.
I don't disagree with you,
I just don't go quite as far
for those reasons.
- Yeah, well, I understand very much
your first pragmatic consideration,
it's perfectly reasonable,
but I do have something to
say about the other reason.
Now, the second reason is
something that was raised
for example, by Howie Trifeel.
And for those of you who are
maybe not familiar with this,
neither one of us talked
about models very much so far.
But there is the standard way
of understanding logical truth
and logical consequence is to say that
there is a totality of models.
Each model represents either
a way our language could be
or a way the world could have been.
But the non-logical properties
change from model to model,
but the logical properties are fixed.
So disjunction is always disjunction,
identity is always identity,
but a property like
being a man in one model,
it's that property,
another it's the property of being a woman
or being an odd number or
being an even number and so on.
And so what is true in
all models is said to be
what is logically true,
what couldn't be false,
what is true due to the
logical structure of sentences
or logical meaning of sentences,
which is fixed in all models.
Now, models are usually a thought to be
a set theoretical construct.
And a model consists of a
universe, which is a set
and then objects and subsets
and relations and so on,
which represent the properties
that we are talking about
in a particular sentence.
And the laws that govern models
are the laws of set theory
and how many models there are,
how many possibilities
are represented by models
is the number of possibilities
that can be represented
by sets in set theory.
Now, one distinctive
aspect of set theory is
that set theory can represent sets
but it cannot represent
the totality of all sets,
and one might say that what is really real
is the totality of all sets.
And that set theory cannot not represent.
And so models, set theoretical models
do not represent this either.
So truth in all models is in some way
not truth in all possibilities,
maybe even not in the real reality.
Now, in my view this is
not a conclusive argument.
And the reason is that
we need to distinguish
between the general idea
and its implementation
of processification, there is
nothing about the general idea
of logic that to be true is to be true
in all formally possible situations.
And set field, in principle
we could have implemented
a different field.
Russell, for example,
in his theory of types,
didn't use axiomatic set theory
and didn't have this problem.
And so I see this just as
a matter of implementation.
I think the idea is right,
but we still need to find
an adequate mathematical
theory that will enable us
to implement it precisely.
Another point which is relevant is that
even if we use set
theory, there is a point
that was emphasized by Mcgee and others
that in set theory itself there
are reflection principles.
And these reflection
principles say that even though
the totality of sets is
not represented by a set,
there are so many sets and so
many variations between sets
that it is sufficient to
present any type of structure,
including the class structure.
So once again, there are
questions about this point,
but the first point seems
to me more important that
the problem is in implementation
and not in principle.
I wonder what you think about this, Alex?
- I think you could be right about that,
I don't disagree with that.
As I say, it's not
disagreement, it's hesitation
because I haven't seen
a convincing implementation of that yet.
That could be my ignorance,
which is why I hesitate
to take that step.
If there were a precise
cogent in implementation
that undercut all those doubts,
then I'd join you immediately.
And there may be one and
maybe you can imagine one,
but I haven't quite seen one yet,
so that's why I'm a little hesitant.
- Yeah, and I think it's partly a matter
of how you treat philosophical results.
For me, you can have solid
philosophical results
even without having yet
a mathematical implementation for it.
And the philosophical
result stands at its own,
but there are many people who
would not agree and would say,
we actually need an implementation
in order to substantiate
the philosophical result.
- So in that way it might be a
matter of temperament almost.
On the second point about reflection,
again, I think you're right,
but again, I mean reflection is sensitive
to the language of the
set theory and so on.
- Yeah, it's an open question,
the issue of reflection,
and interesting.
- Yes, but thank you for that response
to my second hesitation.
- And what was your last point, I forgot?
- My last point was that
the talk of formal laws
and formal structure was in a way,
wasn't sure how much
explanation it was giving you
because it seemed to be
restating some of the points
of the infinity of logic,
but just putting it in
more metaphysical language.
And so as I see it, it wasn't
giving you very much else
an explanation, if B
is an explanation of A,
it's gotta go quite a bit beyond A,
and it seemed like saying
A the same thing as A,
but in a much more physical language,
excuse me, metaphysical language.
- Yeah, and I think that
this is partly because
my perspective is a little bit more
general systemic perspective,
knowledge in general.
We want to know how the world is.
So we want to know whether
there are formal properties,
things in the world
have formal properties,
and we want to know whether
there are formal laws
that govern the world.
This is a question which
is interesting in itself,
but it's also connection
to the question of truth.
I mean, we were talking about consequence,
about implication, but
in infinitistic logic
of the kind you talk about,
there are also logical truth.
And the question is whether
logical truth are really true.
And if they're true in
virtue of what they are true,
I think that the advantage
of going to the world
and say that they are
true due to formal laws
that govern the world,
give you a straightforward
explanation of why they are true.
And if you give this
up, it's not clear to me
how you can establish truth.
This is the main issue that bothers me.
- I see that, thank you.
Yeah, I think I have so
far declined to answer
that question, and it is a
question that needs an answer.
I certainly agree with that, yeah.
- Okay, so I think one
more question has showed up
in the chat from Ed Brandon.
And so he asked, I don't think
it's an ignorant question,
"What is the relation between
valid infinitary arguments,
Professor Bizo gave,
and what is called
mathematical induction?"
- Okay, yeah, so mathematical induction,
the principle of mathematical
induction is a principle about
the natural numbers, zero,
one, two, three and so on,
or some people just start at one.
And it says that if zero has the property,
and secondly, if a
number has the property,
then it's successor has the property,
from those two facts, you
can infer that every number
has the property.
And so that's specific to the
natural numbers, of course,
it doesn't hold in lots of other domains.
So for example, if you throw
in the negative integers,
the principle of mathematical
induction isn't gonna hold,
because you could have starting
at zero in transmitting,
but never getting to
the negative integers.
Valid infinitary arguments
however are completely general
and apply to any subject
matter whatsoever.
So it can be about numbers,
natural numbers, real numbers,
but also about physical
situations, whatever you like.
Ed, if that does not answer your question,
then feel free to ask a follow-up.
- Let me see if there is...
Yeah, I don't see a follow-up from Ed.
- I mean, to put it very broadly,
the principle of mathematical
induction specific
to arithmetic, to the natural numbers,
logic, infinitary of finite.
Gila and I both think it's infinitary,
applies to any kind of domain.
- Much broader, right?
- Yes.
There is a potential confusion
with the word induction here
because induction is
used in all sorts of ways
outside academic uses, you can be inducted
into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
But even within philosophy
and mathematics,
it's used in different ways.
And so when I was talking
about non-deductive knowledge,
that's sometimes called
inductive knowledge,
but that can be a bit confusing.
So I was keen to just say non-deductive
to not call it inductive.
- Great, if there are
no further questions,
I think we can draw
our session to a close.
And so let me thank both Gila and Alex
for a wonderful discussion,
a great lecture yesterday
and for a really nice discussion today.
Clarifying points of view,
points of convergence
and the very few points of
divergence in your views.
But thank you so much for enriching
and teaching us all so much.
Yeah, so let's give a round of applause
to our speakers today.
And yeah, we're really deeply grateful
to both of you for coming.
Thanks, bye.
- Thanks, bye.
- Bye-bye.